who's the one actor that You' met who is
one of your favorites and they couldn't
have
been better and
nicer oh wow um and you were like wow
thank God they were
cool uh wow that's a good
question um kind of I gotta it's a tough
one but
uh I got to say all the biggest actors
like the biggest name I've worked with
have been awesome you know Downey's
awesome Clooney's awesome Brad Pitt's
awesome uh yeah those those three it's
the smaller ones that aren't that great
right the ones that aren't as big maybe
you get a little attitude with that you
know the one it's not even the smaller
ones it's the ones it's the big ones
that have lasted a really long time and
then you're like oh I'm this is why they
lasted because they're
nice like they're not just talented but
they're super nice and they make it easy
for people to shoot movies with them and
then you go oh that's the key is just be
like super nice who is the worst you
can't say
it but you have one in your mind right
you have one in your mind the worst
famous person that I met as a fan as a
fan I'll tell you I'll tell you I'll
tell you one thing okay um I'll tell you
funny story really quick okay and then
and then I'll I I'll try to make this
quick I'm
21 or 22 years old 23 actually and I get
my first lead part in a small Indie
movie tiny Indie movie it's going to
shoot in New York City and the producer
has us come to her apartment in Tribeca
for a table read and I go to the table
read and you know we do the reading and
the director is like hey stick around
after the table read I want to talk to
you specifically about your role I said
great I stick around there's Pizza there
and I'm 23 years old and at the end of
our no session he says hey you want to
take the pizza with you and I'm like
hell yeah and I walk out of her
apartment and directly across the
hall with their apart with his apartment
door open holding his apartment door
open is Robert [__] dairo right and I
freeze because I had one week prior just
seen Raging Bull and I I felt I froze I
was scared of him and he slammed the
door in my face and I I I can't believe
it Happ an I turn and standing by the
elevator in this building are two are
his two twin children he had two he had
twins and they're they're like four or
five at this point maybe six and they're
standing there and they see that I have
pizza and they want the pizza right and
I'm like no you can't have the pizza and
I'm also super afraid to go knock on
Dao's door and say hey you left your
kids out here I assume he knows the kids
are out there like I I gotta get out of
there man I just got my the door slammed
in my face I'm scared and like an idiot
I push the elevator button and the
elevator comes and these two get in the
elevator okay so now Robert Dao's four
or five-year-old twins are in the
elevator of this building he's in his
apartment if I leave to go knock on his
door to tell him the elevator door
closes they go downstairs so I'm stuck
with his twins I go into the elevator
with them I say here's what's going to
happen they're like can we have the
pizza I'm like no I'm not going to touch
them I'm not going to force them
physically force them out so I'm like
here's what's going to happen we're
going to go down to the lobby I'm GNA
press your floor and you go right back
up and you go home okay so we go down to
the lobby I press their floor Lobby door
closes 22y old 23 year old stupid me is
like okay I did it get out of here go
home few years ago Tribeca Film Festival
I'm a juror they have this lunch
Aaron Rogers is
there and there's Robert dairo and I
think you know I'm going to tell Robert
dairo this
story so I go up to Rob daero and I say
hey Mr Dao I'm so sorry to bother you my
name's Dave and I'm just I just want to
let you know I'm a huge fan of yours and
I just want to tell you a funny story
and I tell him the story I just told you
and he laughs he laughs thank God he's
not pissed he laughs yeah his kids are
okay they're grown up nothing ever
happened I go they they they announce
hey okay everybody now we're all going
to go upstairs and uh and deliberate on
our
films I said great I go to the elevator
to go upstairs to this room where I'm
going to deliberate with Aaron Rogers
and whatever waiting for the elevator
and Robert dairo comes and stands next
to me waiting for the same elevator and
like an idiot I turn to him I go well
you'll be the third dairo I ride an
elevator with and start laughing and he
goes I'm going to take the stairs and he
did
oh my God I'm gonna take the
stairs think I take the stairs and boom
took the stairs and that was it 75y old
man took the
stairs you should have said I hope you
fall down
them you old [__]